بعض الانظمه التي نتوقع من الصين التركيز
عليها في ميزانيه هذا العام تشمل الجيل
الجديد من طائرات الشبح المقاتله
وتكنولوجيا الصواريخ المتقدمه والاقمار
الاصطناعيه العسكريه واجهزه الاستشعار
وانواعا اخرى من الاسلحه المتقدمه مثل
الدبابات ومنظومات اطلاق الصواريخ وغيرها
هناك عده طرق للنظر الى كيفيه تحديد اي
دوله لميزانيتها الدفاعيه اعتقد انه من
غير الانصاف القول ان الصين تخفي شيئا
فعلينا ان ننظر الى اسلوب انفاق الصين
للعام الكامل واذا ما نظرنا من زوايا
متعدده فسنرى ان الموازنه صحيحه
وما يقصده الامريكيون هو ان الصينيين
اعلنوا عن بعض انفاقاتهم ضمن الميزانيه
الدفاع ولكن هناك انظمه اخرى مثل
المنظومات العسكريه الفضائيه التي تقع تحت
ميزانيه الفضاء لكن اذا ما اخذنا هذه
الميزانيه بالنظر الاعتبار وجمعناها الى
ميزانيه الدفاع فسيكون الرقم اكبر بكثير
[موسيقى]